good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy wednesday it is
hump day
a favorite day here at the morning toast
a favorite day we have the stripes
brothers and spirit to celebrate hump
day with us and before we do anything
else
i need to compliment claudia's outfit
for everybody watching on youtube you're
in for a treat claudia looks like the
picture of class it's giving nancy myers
she's giving coastal grandmother it's
giving nancy myers tell us about this
look today well um
jackie wore these pants the other day on
the toes and she was like claudia you
need these pants from spanx and like
they're just like the pant of the moment
like they're like these spanx white
trousers but they have an elastic band
they're made with spanx material you
can't see through them there's no zipper
and they just look so classy i have to
say look i'm not loving the way they
look but i'm loving the way they feel
and i'm just at a point in my life where
like feelings are gonna have to um take
a precedent over looks okay well you
look really great that's what's great
about thank you so much it's like a
whole new era for you that is so nice of
you to compliment my trousers by the way
we've really come full circle i'm
wearing culottes you are and just like
everything else culottes are the downton
abbey
2022. what would 2018 jackie say if she
saw me wearing culottes
she would say i told you so you
literally would yeah um we've got a
great show it's wednesday it's hump day
it's june 1st it is pride month
i know is that crazy that is crazy the
month is over and now it has begun
that's the crazy thing about months they
end and then a new one begins
it's just so crazy beyond i haven't had
a chance to process this morning that
it's june like last night i was driving
and i saw some pride flags out i was
like oh tomorrow is june 1st and then
this morning it's been a long morning
for me and i didn't even realize
happy pride month happy pride month
y'all i'm also back on cameo for the
first month of pride month with all
proceeds going to rainbow railroad so if
you want to see a gorgeous face
um with gorgeous pants with gorgeous
pants i'll try and get my pants in the
video if you request one today how about
that okay
does that work for everyone that is
worthwhile that's called marketing baby
yeah enticing the customer that's so
great of you yeah well i love i really
like doing cameo but i don't think i
could be on it like full time it's a lot
of work like
you have to be like glammed up all the
time i'm not gonna be making cameos
looking like a beast that's not nice
people are paying a premium 100 and i
did raise my price a little bit because
like it's for charity you know yeah and
as leanne lockett says the charity world
is really small the charity world is
everything i'm excited because i picked
the stories today claudia did pick the
stories because i was running behind and
they are very i wouldn't i would have
picked maybe one of these stories out of
the five so i'm excited because they're
kind of twisted no and there's a theme i
wonder if everyone can guess today's
theme there's a theme in today's episode
and the stories they highlight uh
justice for claudia we'll do a quiz at
the end to make sure you guys understood
the theme of today's episode that's
today's assignment justice for claudia i
look forward to justice being served as
always it's just like every person who
i've ever had the bad feeling about is
out here exposing themselves you know oh
okay so you're just gonna give away the
theme right now yeah i feel like i
already gave it away yeah no it's like
claudia was right yeah which doesn't
happen to me a lot i'm usually wrong
actually like cool
like cool up downtown reading
reading speaking of reading yesterday i
finished charlie hepworth's book the
younger wife awesome i gave it four
stars she's just great and then i
started a new book so counselor you know
me and counts are like the same type of
like you know
old lady book club porn and she was like
you're gonna love this one so like i'm
purchasing it yesterday on my kindle as
i pressed purchase it didn't even occur
to me to check the
the length of the book snatcher would
never recommend anything crazy she
recommended a 600 page book
we recorded redheads last night we all
go around and talk about the other books
we read during the month she was telling
us about this book how she loved it so
much she wishes that she picked it for
the redheads it was 500 pages but it
went by in a flash 572. she said it was
as good as tested because good as
anything ever has been it's giving tessa
bailey are you enjoying i am and i'm
already halfway through like i was
literally um just i couldn't put it down
right so i forget what it's called i
forget what it's called also give me a
second usually i remember everything but
something about the title just like it's
so it's literally just like basic words
string together you know what i mean
it's like this was the way it was you
know
that's literally that's the title it's
called hold on things the way we were or
something hold on
literally things we never got over okay
lit by lucy score it's giving porn it's
giving rustic small virginia town it's
good
i love that for you yeah part of it like
is written extremely poorly but like you
just like you don't care you know yeah
no and that makes it easier to get
through yeah we recorded redheads last
night it was so funny it was the first
time we were in studio since november
because of like omnicron pregnancy
delivery etc and it was really wonderful
to get the girls back together so now
i'm really in a reading state of mind we
recapped the book which was really
really a good book and i'm excited for
everyone to hear it will drop on
thursday and it's never too late to
become a redhead now let's talk about
the younger wife because wait but who
chooses the next redhead's book rebecca
chooses the next book oh should i spoil
it no joke oh okay
i'll tell you i'll give you guys
the backstory behind what she chose
because everyone loves to complain about
whatever book we're choosing at present
so she actually took a recommendation
from the redheads facebook group so she
said if you don't like it you guys can
turn on each other right right right
oh you're not going to say the book
right now no because it drops on
thursday oh it's not out yet right you
love a little mystique around the red
heads are so mysterious beyond gotta be
mysterious always oh wait um so we also
have to your toasters today because it
is wednesday we've got five in my
opinion
amazingly chosen obviously these stories
were chosen by someone really
intelligent and beautiful yeah there's
no food news there's no biz news yeah
that's how you know it's like bottom of
the barrels like when we're talking
about food news i personally like some
of those human interest stories but
you don't yeah well there actually was
one story that i could have chosen that
i didn't that bordered on food news but
it was just like kim you know clapping
back at everyone yeah but she just
clapped back at everyone she don't worry
devoured everything in the beyond me
commercial and i guess just none of it
made it to cut yeah in the commercial
she was eating
like
she was eating but there was also scenes
where she was like oh it's so good and
the chicken nugget didn't have a bite
out of it but it's called movie magic no
and it's called you can have try to
chicken nugget and then talk about it at
a later date yeah people really think
they're like you know inspector gadget
they're like she didn't take it but this
is
yeah the internet has empowered a lot of
amateur um investigators and sometimes
it's fun and sometimes it's not no
sometimes it's just so sweet sometimes
it's so fun and it's like oh my god when
they realized that kim photoshopped true
true into a photo where stormy was there
like that was crazy and then she
admitted it recently that was really
crazy agreed
one night in the chicken nugget
no not that deep but when they when tick
tock figured out 818 tequila like before
it came out do you remember that like
that was a fun journey to follow yeah
yeah so there's the good and the bad the
good and the bad but that's the internet
man and that's life this is episode two
of us going viral right um how are you
feeling i'm feeling great like my tick
tock is blowing out i've gotten like 5
000 followers in the last like couple
days i'm just so happy for you for a
thirst monster like me like incredibly
exciting and let me ask you something
like is it making you happy
is it fulfilling you that's a good
question um
no actually
do you think if it was like a million
followers yes he fulfilled like really
five thousand that's it we had over a
million followers over a million views
we're at 1.3 million views 5 000 of you
thought it was funny enough to like it
and follow me
how many likes does it have like 200 000
so like of those 200 000 only 5000
decided to follow me it's disgusting
it's disgusting okay how many followers
would it take for you to feel fulfilled
i have a hundred and fifty thousand
that's like micro influencer and i've
been a macro influencer for like eight
years now
so i will feel you're not used to the
micro life no and i don't like it at all
like it's not fun so i um
i'll feel good when i get to 500 000.
okay if i get to 500. that's pretty
like low for you
i thought we're gonna say a million my
bar is incredibly low yeah and it's just
it used to be like you expected three
million on tick tock no but yeah because
at first it was like once i go viral
then the followers will come build it
and they will come and i've built it and
no one's coming no they don't like what
you're selling i'm sorry no but i think
they will like these clips i think
you're on a really good path me too you
and you just have to be consistent it's
like anything else yeah and they they
have to like what they see in there for
you page and then go to your page and
there's more of that thing that they
liked yeah i guess i've just like you
know you're always doing one-offs so
it's just because they like this one
thing from you there's nothing else like
that on your page i guess i'm just used
to like
i really haven't had to hustle for like
likes in a really long time you know
what i mean yeah and it sounds like the
dumbest conversation but like you know i
reached a point in my social career like
a couple years ago where like
things just got engagement and you
didn't have to try so hard and so i
guess in a good way i'm being challenged
creatively yeah um because i don't think
i've been creatively challenged on
instagram in quite a while yeah and i
think it's okay if like you're not
getting
that many likes as long as you know you
don't put too much stock into it yeah no
i mean i definitely i don't know for
sure like i'm not upset at all i'm not
saying you i'm saying like one in
general you know no i know what you mean
like is it keeping me up at night yes no
it's not it's not i'm not tired at all
yeah no you sleep great she goes to bed
at 10 p.m i
i'm not good at a lot of things in this
world but something i am good at is
getting like a full nine hours of sleep
twelve
yeah sometimes yeah it depends seven
weeks i'm like you know what let's be
crazy and stay up till eleven but most
of the time like when it's nine o'clock
like the lights go out and i'm in bed by
ten i mean i'm sleeping by ten so lovely
yeah it's a child free life so i know
it's not gonna last forever so i'm
enjoying it while i can yeah that's all
you need to do yeah okay well should we
get into the amazing stories handpicked
by beautiful stunning and smart queen we
shall without further ado here are the
past five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast and today's
episode is brought to you by
oh my gosh
let him know about bruce and then i have
another fun fact about bruce bruce is an
electric toothbrush that will change the
way you think about brushing your teeth
with powerful sonic technology and ultra
gentle bristles the brush the brush
excuse me
redefines what it means to have super
clean teeth it's like that feeling when
you just leave the dentist a fresh whole
clean mouth but you get it every single
day so when you buy the brush kit it
includes the electric toothbrush three
brush heads a magnetic charging station
and a sleek travel case they use
industry leading sonic technology to
produce 42 000 brushes per minute which
is 300 times 300
brush strokes per minute um their
battery life lasts forever lasts like 30
days so you can charge it but like if
you're traveling you don't really need
to bring your charger unless you're
traveling for over a month um so it's
perfect for traveling and keeping your
countertop charger cord free it's slim
and sleek makes it easy to throw it in
your purse or your bag on the daily and
they release sickening new colors all
the time i just got a new one it's like
a magenta
and i was still using like my stunning
millennial pink ones so i decided to be
incredibly generous and give the magenta
one to ben
um
because i had been gatekeeping bruce i'm
not gonna lie and he's obsessed of
course he is it's so beautiful i love
magenta for him i'm sure they look so
great side by side
you know a little color contrasting
for any breastfeeding mamas out there
it's really a great toothbrush cheese on
a clog duct that's not in the copy but
that's just a tip of the day what do you
mean like because you need a vibrating
uh
device to massage out the clog
and i use my boot
oh that's funny um get 20 off when you
pick your bruce toothbrush kit and the
plan when you go to bruce.com toast
that's 20 off when you go to bruce.com
toast and bruce is spelled b-r-u-u-s-h
dot com slash toast
[Music]
i would love for them to make a
commercial for television like with
bruno and he's just like running around
saying
what about theo and theo's directing
he's a
more behind the camera kind of guy yeah
he has the vision so true bruno is just
a pretty face so true
okay first story for claudia matthew
morrison has been fired from so you
think you can dance for flirty messages
that made a contestant uncomfortable new
details are emerging about matthew
morrison's sudden departure from his
judging gig on so you think you can
dance a source close to the fox reality
show tells people that morrison was
fired from the series quote after he had
an inappropriate relationship with a
female contestant quote they didn't have
sex but he reached out to her through
flirty direct messages on social media
she felt uncomfortable with his line of
comments and went to producers who then
got fox involved he was fired after they
did their own investigation the source
adds that morrison and the unidentified
female contestant never met up offset it
was just messages that crossed the line
okay so a few days ago they announced
that he was leaving for like breaking
protocol and nobody knew what that meant
like it's a coveted protocol a lot of
people were like he's so creepy like
he probably was being inappropriate and
now we have like full confirmation that
that's what it is um and obviously uh
i just feel justified in like hating
matthew martin since the day i met him
um and you know what like even though
like this never should have happened i
feel like things like this like back in
the day like would get swept under the
rug so like get on fox for like actually
doing something about it you know yeah
totally like protecting the contestants
yeah and like stopping it in its tracks
right and that's not letting the fact
that he's like a celebrity right or the
fact that like they never met up like
the fact that it was just right this
girl didn't have to you know endure
anything else right and
they took action yeah so i i'm glad
about that matthew emerson is so so
inappropriate especially i mean it's
inappropriate any time yes and
unsolicited for learning messages but
the dynamic on a competition show like
that like the power that the judges have
and the contestants like it's already
such a power imbalance on every level
and so to abuse your power in that way
is gross twisted no he's so gross and
like i feel like you know the internet
has like hated decided to hate matthew
martin like starting like a year ago but
never for anything like actually
concrete just like weird things he does
like videos he posts uh with the kids
singing with the kids like characters
he's please played but he's never
actually like done anything like that
warrants like the hatred but now he has
and i feel justified that's really funny
yeah so it's a good day for us matthew
morrison haters yes you are
justified and you know what so what the
show is so you think you can dance right
yeah they really keep saying sytcd as
say yes to the dress because we all know
like so you think
every time i've been seeing these
stories no it's literally saying to the
dress i've been seeing people posting
about this and like using that acronym
i'm like matthew martin was on say yes
to the dress it's beyond confusing
um
also i don't know why he was chosen like
in the first place for first of all like
he can't have a high q score like people
do not like him
two like there are so many celebrities
who also dance with the advent of tic
toc they really should have like charlie
demilio there's so many people they
could have gotten to be a judge on a
dance show and like why matthew morrison
literally why he's literally irrelevant
does nobody remember the grinch
what body did matthew morrison buried
like with some executive that he keeps
getting jobs ask auntie
ask james corden
ask auntie yeah there's something like
why would he still be working
he really hasn't been relevant in years
no but like he really should because
he's someone who's a good person to plug
in like he can do it all he can sing he
can dance he can act but like he hasn't
had a job like
a relevant job in years and then he had
the grinch which was a colossal failure
like made people despise him so like why
would anyone cast him in anything i
don't know
i mean i would just do annie live every
year instead of the grinch yeah but like
i could think of a thousand people who
would be great for like a dance
competition tv show judge the new judges
this season they swapped out nigel
lithgow and mary murphy with jojo siwa
and stephen twitch boss oh twitch from
ellen see that's a good one he's huge on
tick tock
um jojo's great and i guess they wanted
someone like traditional not digital
because jojo and twitch are both really
digital but like jenna dewan
literally anyone she's been rather quiet
yeah but she was involved in there's a
lot of new dancing shows so i think she
was on a competitor so you can't world
of dance yeah the one with j.lo the
masked dancer right oof flop low point
flop central i don't even know if it's
premiered yet really i don't know we
just talked about the fact that it was
going to be i mean the fact that the
masked singer um like became such a
phenomenon like i remember when i like
first saw a commercial for and i was
first introduced to the concept of the
show i'm like wow hollywood has really
lost its mind like this is the and
people are obsessed with the show it has
like a cult following and i see clips
all the time
of like big reveals you know candy
burris i think won
people are obsessed and it's kind of
good what's so crazy about is that it's
so protected like the identities there's
no spoilers that actually every year i
don't know who wins yeah because it will
never be in a headline and i'll never
click the link and it makes you think
like how the bachelor is unable to keep
like a single spoiler because there's no
respect for the bachelorette right these
people and publications respect the hell
out of the mass singer for some reason
yeah there's like this unspoken
universal bond to
no it's so weird it's such a good call
yeah
okay are you ready for our next story
some one direction drama oh yeah ex
podcasting drama
liam payne is has been dragged for
airing 1d's dirty laundry on podcast
twitter users roasted liam payne for
airing his former one direction band
mates's dirty laundry in a new interview
he appeared on logan paul's impulsive
podcast on tuesday and reflected on not
only the boy band's many highs but also
their infighting as teens and personal
drama in more recent years fans were
particularly upset over liam taking a
point and dig at zayn whose
ex-girlfriend gigi infamously describes
zayn as a respectful king during the
2020 twitter spat with logan's brother
jake paul
um given that zayn was in charge in 2021
for harassing yolanda hadid liam said on
the podcast of her tweet he said that
one didn't age very well in an attempt
to explain himself he then said there's
many reasons why i dislike zayn and
there's many reasons why i'll always be
on his side
okay then contradictory right the one
directioners came from him saying liam
talking [ __ ] about zayn as if he didn't
cheat on his fiance last week right okay
so there's like a lot to unpack here
first of all i didn't think what he said
about zayn was so
terrible um he just said like that
didn't age well because then like zayn
turned out to like
be doing some bad things so i didn't
think that was so crazy yeah literally
so i didn't think that was so crazy the
part that the clip that i saw going
around which was beyond cringe
was talking about the journey during x
factor when like he thought he you know
lost this big opportunity and then they
called those five boys back in and put
them into a band he said like how you
know his understanding of how that
situation went down was like simon made
a promise to him
to liam that he's gonna do this group
and like in two years he'll be set and
he took liam's face and built the whole
band around liam and liam was the star
and it was like giving like pick me
energy like
really i
i wasn't there but i don't think that's
how it went down
i don't think that's how it went down
but why would anyone lie about that
especially when like i think he can look
in the mirror and say like harry is the
bigger star right and then he was going
on about all their you know
solo career saying his song was the
first to hit a billion streams like even
if that's technically true like
come on like for real he just must have
like people around him who are like
liam's the greatest they like shut out
the rest of the world probably doesn't
know like actually the board i would say
level of like solo career fame of dr one
direction it's definitely harry and then
niall
and then i would say the rest of the
three are you know what zayn is like
known because the uh who's the fifth
lewis literally yeah he but see the
thing i see okay i want to offer a
rebuttal louie
it's not like he really tried you know
what i mean which is like there's kind
of there's honor in that yeah whereas
like remember
zane's last album he had like that big
truck going around the city like gigi
was taking pictures like i could not
name one lyric from one song from that
entire album like that is i think that's
considered like the definition of a flop
yeah so is that better or worse than
louis who just didn't even do anything i
don't know he had hits though back in
the day yes he did he had pillow talk in
the taylor swift song
yeah but
what i was gonna say about this like the
fans seem to be pissed that like liam's
running his mouth about the one
direction days on a podcast and it's
like if that's not what he's doing like
it's been 10 years since they broke up
almost like
it's time to talk about the ins and outs
and the of the band on a podcast i
totally agree see i'm like conflicted in
the sense where it's like well you
obviously have nothing else going on if
this is what you're doing um
but also it's like we want to know we
one we want to know too like going on a
podcast especially like if it's someone
who maybe you're friends with offline
like it's just a fun activity especially
for someone who probably has a lifetime
worth of stories share with the class i
agree normalized talking about what
happened in one direction and
they do have this connection because of
the respectful king tweet so he was on
the logan paul podcast so it's relevant
and if logan didn't mention it that
would have been weird yeah by the way
that's like one of the weirdest moments
in pop culture history jake paul and
gigi needs twitter feud yeah um also why
people are quaking is because last week
the weirdest thing happened so liam is
engaged and he has like um a million fan
pages for him and his fiancee and
somebody posted like a cute it was like
a picture of liam hugging his fiancee
from the back but you couldn't see their
faces and the caption on the fan camera
was like so cute maya and lee and blah
blah and maya commented it was like it's
really difficult to see photos of your
man like with someone else this is not
me please stop tagging me and i guess
now him and his fiance are broken up so
it's like when you're going through your
own you know scandal it's not a good
look to go on the podcast like talk
about other people's scandals do you
think this was recorded before that for
sure
so but like people don't care like they
see it now right
i mean
so they're not engaged anymore i don't
think so and then who's the one who is
engaged to like the judge the judge liam
are they still together i think they had
a baby together yeah i think so too no
they're not still together oh so like
liam has his own like messiness and it's
just like
be quiet no i like it keep talking agree
uh nor and like this may be a dumb
question but like
one direction's hiatus like
a breakup right like we're not still
waiting are we was it a hiatus yes
i think that it could be like the jonas
brothers where they really do their own
thing they enjoy their own thing and
then realize there might be value in
coming back together the problem is
is a rock star harry like has literally
no reason
one direction was never going to do that
i i know arc steencella they would have
but you have like you know what i mean
yeah no harry's too far gone i think
he's too far gone even
niall's success which is big like i do
think if there was like a chore like he
would hop on you know and agree
yeah of course
yeah
so
so it's over i think it's a no that's so
crazy i've made peace with it because
we're getting bops from everyone i know
but
and they're really good don't get me
wrong like i love of course it's not one
direction it's not even close to like
the serotonin boost that one direction
songs give me
i personally i can't
you know wait for rain in this drought i
know because everyone and i'm waiting
just for little mix yeah i know that's
the eggs i put my in my basket that's
the other question because they're also
like a british band from x factor doing
a quote-unquote hiatus and someone left
and then it became a hiatus right it's
it's giving one direction it is but i
have faith in my girls so do i unless
one of their solo careers becomes huge
no one's done a solo career but i follow
like all these twitter accounts like
they're all signed with different
management companies and record labels
like four solo endeavors
that's not going to work for me yeah no
they're they they i think they all plan
on doing their own thing that's not
going to work for me so rethink it yeah
i don't think that's what the fans want
no it's definitely not and like i
was on little mix talk and so many clips
from their farewell tour were going
around and like in the final show they
were hysterically crying it's like well
don't cry just get back together just do
another show no it's literally in your
control 100 you don't have to be doing
this like at all
it's literally your choice
are you ready for our next story some
more justifications for claudius hatred
i am and this time she's turned me as
well thank you
charlie puth shares adam levine's
reaction to him masturbating to maroon
5. i just like these headlines
the whole thing it's crazy and i just
think it's like a general thing in
hollywood like you don't have to tell us
everything you know
yeah
some things like can be kept to yourself
so here are the details that you're all
dying to know charlie puth revealed in
an nsfw new interview that he once
masturbated to a maroon 5 song much to
front man adam levine's displeasure the
first song i ever jerked off to was
[ __ ] this love by maroon 5. he told
bustle on tuesday years later charlie
told adam levine about the experience
though the former voice coach didn't
react with much enthusiasm charlie said
now i'm good friends with adam levine i
told him and he was like that's really
weird he also shared that he didn't lose
his virginity until he was 21 years old
when he played a small town in boston
he also spoke openly about the value of
sex and how it intertwines with his
music career he said this is a really
weird sentence but if you took the
instrumental only of my music i want
people to almost get turned on by the
frequency
okay
shall i keep going okay there's more
sure
if you must
however he noted that he can't listen to
music while getting it on because he
will just start focusing on the notes
he said
i will analyze the music playing in the
background and i'll start to see the
music notes in my head and i will not be
able to get hard
well
that's kind of contradictory because
it's like but you jerked off to music so
doesn't music wow get you off loophole
loophole the thing is like i'm feeling
shame i'm feeling
embarrassado i'm feeling humiliation
mortification
on behalf of charlie booth like first of
all we don't care like at all like not
in the slightest what you do in the
bedroom like we literally could not care
less and he's just so cringy and i feel
like when he was like saying this to the
interviewer like he really thought he
was being like you know like mick jagger
like sex music sexual yeah like he
thought he was doing something and what
he's doing is absolutely nothing wait
this article is so funny like i think it
was co-written by you okay one one place
booth has been open about his sexual
personalities through his tick tock
account there he posts a mosh of content
including a look into his musical
process some thirst traps and other
strange content like two butterflies
having sex yes he was even called out by
comedian sarah shower for being
incredibly horny on tick tock she
tweeted
if someone doesn't [ __ ] soon
fear the worse
that's incredibly funny and incredibly
on point i've been telling you there is
something weird about charlie puth i
will stop defending him i knew of the
floor i knew it there was just something
weird in his tick tocks like he really
thinks and i'm sure he is like very
musically inclined very talented but he
thinks that makes him like super human
and the way he like talks to people on
tick tock and his content is so cringe
and so condescending and it's like he
really thinks that he is like like the
rolling stones like he thinks that he is
that and it's it's giving me
embarrassment like for him it's just
it's horrible and this was while it was
shocking to read it wasn't shocking to
digest like i knew that that is who
charlie truth was like i knew it
it's reminding me of the little brother
from zoe 101
okay
you know oh yes yes yes sorry i think
i'm in his character yes if you haven't
looked at the little boy from zoe 101's
current tick tock account like you you
will die of shame like no you have to
it's he's not embarrassed i actually
like you almost have to resist respect
the courage the courage and
it's like you would hear charlie puth on
the radio and you would never expect
like this is his tick tock this is his
personality yeah watch zoey 101 you
would never expect that dustin is doing
bdsm on tick tock so i think he's like
doing all this like
to
change people's perception of him in
into a more like sexual way and it's
only making us like think you're weird
so stop yeah i think he probably has one
of those complexes that like child stars
have about like going from being like a
teenager or a young person to being like
taken seriously as an adult and i think
a lot of times people think like sex is
the answer the way to do it and it's not
a case in point yeah and i said this a
couple weeks ago like i do think charlie
puth's career had like a weird plateau
where like if he had you know kept the
momentum up that he had in the beginning
of his career like he would have been at
the level that sean mendes is now so i
feel like he's definitely having some
sort of identity crisis and this is he
thinks the solution to
that yeah
i i feel you so just stop
agreed are you ready for our next story
yeah
shannon moekler sells travis barker's
engagement ring for 97k nice shannon
mogler successfully offloaded her
engagement ring from travis barker to 96
thousand five hundred dollars after
putting it up for auction last friday
4.01 round
cut
cartier sparkler received 17 bids on
worthy.com which should not reveal the
identity of the big spender i had a four
carrick cartier less than 100 grand no
that's i mean set on par i think that's
on par because
that's like you price up for cartier
yeah you get like the cartier price tag
but i think only the cartier store can
just right not secondhand right like
same for like tiffany's yeah pay for the
name so definitely in her auction she's
paying for the name but not as much as
if you like left the store with a you
know a fork robin's egg box
so that's pretty good and that must be a
good stone yeah well the thing is is
like what's your philosophy on like
rings after
after a relationship ends
i don't have a strong one i think it's
just like if someone told me that they
were selling their ring i'd be like good
goodbye if someone told me they were
keeping it cause they love how it looks
and they want to wear it to black tie
events and cocktails
dinners i would say great you should
it's gorgeous yeah i don't really have a
philosophy either i think the best way
like if it were me i would like have it
made into a pair of earrings or
something you know yeah but like it's
one gorgeous stone i think i would keep
it as a ring yeah you don't want to
break it up no but the thing is like i
wonder if shanna mochler really needs
the money because
these things increase in value over time
so like she should really hang on to it
for as long as she can and i don't know
if she's doing it like for the money and
the press like i don't know i really
have no clue what shannon mochler's like
finances are like i just know like in
the grand scheme of shannon moekler
kourtney kardashian
um travis barker
sharna burgess brian austin green megan
fox and megan kelly like shannon moekler
came out on bottom like everyone ended
up like bigger and better and happier
except for her like every time i read a
report about her it's like some turn
instagram live with her and her
boyfriend like i just feel like everyone
came out of it on top of that whole like
love
hexagon except for her do you think it's
intentional that she sold the ring like
the same week as the wedding
to like get buzzed yeah yeah she said
i'm sure people would assume that it's
related to the wedding but i simply
wanted to find the proper seller and
worthy.com is the most professional oh
it's an ad
oh oh wait and i go we'll give this
piece the attention it deserves oh she's
making bank on not only the ring but the
pro promotion so head to worthy.com
toast
um also she said she was hoping and sold
for 120k because she said it was worth
160k now that seems really really high
so that means he bought it for 160.
that's what she said i believe that that
sounds fair for four carrots from
cartier
we'll have to we should do some
investigative work let's go to cartier
let's go to cartier get ourselves some
four carrot rings speaking of rings like
my tiffany sweatshirt i do it's really
cool isn't it so cool yeah you look
great today you're like a cool mom oh my
god that's so nice of you not a regular
mom you look great too thank you we are
great looking girls
moguls
by the way yesterday when you were
saying you're giving the assistant
energy i thought you meant ava no
because she's like the assistant kayla
yes
yes now you see the energy i was
channeling and i'm here for it
how to resolve are you ready for our fit
and final story some news that i found
to be quite upsetting yeah
queen elizabeth's flight has been forced
to abort landing due to lightning storm
she's unacceptable queen like seriously
she's a [ __ ] queen and she's 96. my
god people are just like playing with
her life like it's jello
the queen's plane was forced to abort
landing in london on tuesday according
to reports her majesty was traveling
from balmoral in scotland to windsor
castle ahead of the long-awaited
platinum jubilee celebrations according
to the sun the royals 13-seat plane
landing at raf northalt air force base
was caught up in tuesday's heavy storm
forcing the pilot to abort the landing
buckingham palace converts in the outlet
the flight's delay quote the queen's
flight was delayed to a lightning storm
all the correct procedures were followed
and there were no safety concerns oh
please the queen should never have been
in the plane when the weather like
literally
the the the technology we have access to
the radars
the technology we have access to the
technology that they have access to you
know they have better [ __ ] than us like
figure it out stop putting the queen in
harm's way it's like they don't even
care right in anticipation of her big
jubilee
it's disgusting
when is the jubilee and where is she
going she was going back to windsor's to
get ready for the jubilee you know get
her nails done right
hair did get your nails done
that's funny um and it's any day now
what do you think queenie does to get
ready for the platinum jubilee ooh
i feel like these days i feel like these
days she's really low maintenance maybe
back in the day she had a scrub manicure
pedicure for sure yeah a quaff a blowout
you know yeah but i feel like she just
probably sits in front of the tv do you
think she gets a facial no i don't you
think she's really just i think she's
the type especially because she's like
from a different era where it's like
that's you embrace a joke no and it's
like what is this you put it on you take
it off hogwash right right right she's
into the real deal she probably uses
um
ponds cold cream oh totally lathers it
on like rollers yeah
that's so true i love her wait i have so
many questions do you think the queen
bathes or showers fades me too didn't
she have someone in there with her
perhaps probably right yeah he's getting
out of a bath even as like a somewhat
able-bodied 27 year old like i have
almost snapped my neck like pretty much
every time i get out of a tub yeah not
only like is she a woman of a certain
age but she's also the queen like if
she's not getting bathed who is right
right right that's so interesting
what do you think she like wears to
sleep a night like a moo moo a dress to
the floor right yeah that sounds so
uncomfortable no it sounds kind of nice
i like having a piece of fabric between
my thighs like i feel that like to keep
you know the skin separated yeah
separation what do you think the queen
um
what kind of bra do you think she wears
she definitely goes to orchard tree yeah
like old granny bras that we wear yeah
what kind of deodorant you think she
uses uh dove she's classic but is that
like big in britain oh the british stuff
the british equivalent of dove yeah
love that for her did she wear makeup
yes she wears a nice red lip she's a
makeup artist you think she does it
herself oh you know like her lady in
waiting does it i think she has both but
the royals like do like to do their own
makeup you know yeah she did her own for
her wedding day yeah but kate definitely
doesn't do her own hair
no her but she also has great hair yeah
i think megan did her own makeup for her
wedding day too because it's like a
sense of normalcy
they don't want to be in glamour could
never be me they don't want to be in
glam all day like the kardashians they
don't know what they're missing out on
no they really don't no that makes you
feel better than like hair and makeup
this is a beat face oh she does wear a
lot of makeup yeah yeah
gorgeous gorgeous girl we have to have
makeup by mario do her makeup i would
love to see that that's like one of
those facebook videos that goes viral
where they're doing my great
grandmother's makeup like kim kardashian
okay she really looks like her so funny
um okay well those are the past five and
i do enjoy them i i enjoyed them as well
we should switch it up some more we've
also got to your toasters which is our
weekly advice segment for all the new
tick talkers here every wednesday you
can write into deertoasters gmail.com
and we will try and give you our best
possible advice and we'll keep all your
[ __ ] anonymous so dear toasters is
brought to you by pair our eyewear you
are a unique mashup of all your favorite
things and there's a multitude of ways
to express yourself so celebrate all of
that in who you are and who you can be
with customizable prescription glasses
from pear eyewear so you can change your
look up in a snap pair eyewear's base
frame and the magnetic top frame
combination makes it easy to switch up
your styles base frames start at just 60
including the prescription lenses and
there are a hundred hundreds of top
frame designs to match whichever base
frame you choose so i feel like this is
kind of genius like wearing glasses is
fun but like you shouldn't be wearing
the same pair of glasses like to a black
tie gala as you are to
the air the office the airport yeah so
pear eyebrows really smart you can just
like change the top or like a gorgeous
floral a pattern a solid i love that
it's really smart and they have a pair
for a pair so every pair purchased pair
will provide glasses and vision care for
children around the world so get glasses
as unique as you are one pair infinite
style starting at just sixty dollars go
to pair eyewear dot com slash toast for
15 off your first purchase that's 15 off
at p a i r i wear dot com slash toast
all right ready ready
dear claudia and jackie jackie so happy
to have you back from maternity leave i
hope harry is healthy happy and healthy
and ready to share his mama with us that
is so nice so sweet thank you so here's
my situation my boyfriend's best friend
john was engaged to this girl none of
our friend group liked they had a
tumultuous relationship and often broke
up and got back together last summer she
moved states she moved states away and
then dumped him and this has been their
longest time apart while she is building
a new life in california my boyfriend
and i don't live in john city anymore
but we visit about twice a year when we
visit john hosts all of our friends for
game nights my boyfriend and i always go
early to clean up because i believe it
is the only time john's apartment ever
gets cleaned even when john's ex lived
there it was dirty but the last few
times it was truly a pigsty when we
visited last month i noticed that his
ex's stuff was still all over the place
let me remind you they broke up last
summer her used makeup bottles are still
on the bathroom counter her dirty shoes
are by the door trash from her hair dye
is laying out she sounds disgusting we
actually found out that john sleeps on
the couch because their bedroom is even
more full of her junk i fear that he is
just pining for her to come back so i'm
going back to visit later this summer
and i'm wondering if i should do
something about this we want to gather
our friends there but it's honestly
awkward i want to just take a trash bag
and throw out her stuff or even pack it
up and take it to her parents who live
nearby let me remind you we all hated
this girl she was not fun at our parties
and he knows that i feel bad for him but
he's clearly living a sad life and i
feel like he just needs to push
a push to wake up and move on what do
you suggest okay a few things one just
make sure that they're not like still
seeing that's what i was gonna say
that's why he has all her stuff around
but assuming that they're not i think
sometimes like one of the nicest things
that you can do for someone is refresh
their space and it's something that like
they can't probably see to do themselves
or like you know it's really hard to
like go through everything clean
everything out it's also emotional you
also don't realize like how bad it gets
when you just like let [ __ ] pile up
right so assuming they're not back
together like i would say to him john
like i
want to just refresh your space for you
you don't have to do anything other than
like give me your permission and you go
out with my boyfriend for the day and
i'll i'll handle it for you yes but i do
want to say like just by reading this
and again i don't know the situation it
sounds like there's like a really high
chance the girlfriend's still around
yeah like
like a high probability that they're
maybe not back together but definitely
still like hanging out yeah like
before you do that i would just like
triple check right that's what i said
triple check that you know she's not
popping in and using these things but
even if she is like put your [ __ ] away
because it sounds like you might have
misread the situation
yeah like to be completely honest i
thought that's where the story was but
if he's really just like living in the
past with like boxes of hair dye then
you have to help he needs your help yeah
and i don't think he's gonna walk in and
be like oh no where's my trash no he
won't and if you like make it really
cool
and nice looking people really that can
really change someone's
mental space a hundred percent but again
triple check
all right next up hey claude and jack
long time listener first time caller i
love my fiance to death he's the most
kind caring man i've ever met and i
can't wait to spend the rest of my life
with him but he has some bad habits that
i've been having trouble accepting he's
a good job but sometimes he'll sleep
till 10 a.m on a weekday he doesn't care
about how he dresses and he gets annoyed
when i try to help him buy nice clothes
and he drinks a little too much beer do
i just have to accept these things or is
there a chance for change am i making a
big deal out of nothing or is this just
classic guy stuff can you what do i do
annoying behavior sorry on weekdays
here's a good job but on weekdays he'll
sleep till 10 a.m he doesn't care about
how he dresses and he gets annoyed when
she tries to help him buy nice clothes
and he drinks a little too much
okay and this is her fiance
um i'm weak he has a job but he sleeps
until 10 on weekdays maybe he works from
home in the day the workers at 10 so
he's just like from bed to computer i do
think sometimes like these things work
themselves out with age and just like a
new stage in your life and you know say
eventually
he goes back to the office or you guys
have kids like he will have to drink
less and unless you think like it's
actually a problem some of the things
about the clothes doesn't really bother
me me neither like and that's that i
think you can chalk up to guy stuff 10
a.m isn't that late yeah i know i'm like
i don't know 10.
he gets a bit disgusting every day like
that's pretty if you said
if you said two yeah
even if you said like twelve well like
ten minutes at noon ten oh they said two
i said noon and or two right twenties
like still very much the morning
yeah that's okay it's a little late it's
not he's not up in adam right but it's
not that bad you know that i think
you're being like a little harsh the the
beer is definitely um like just
something you should watch you know why
don't you guys do one of those like
30-day cleanses together well it sounds
like if he won't even let her buy nice
clothes like he's definitely not gonna
do a cleanse with her they're very
different things try it yeah i want to
worry about the clothes i wouldn't the
quills don't bother me and i don't think
that's a
an important thing but it's always good
to do a cleanse 30 days no drinking see
how you guys feel people love it i did
sober january once and look at me now
sober look at me now super 2022 sober
2022 super yearly except for sprints
um so yeah i feel like you're
you're probably fine yeah don't worry
and don't be so harsh like 10 am is
still early for some of us
[Laughter]
all right third and final one hey
claudia and jackie you guys are my
favorite part of the day i'm an og
toaster and i just know you're the ones
to go to about advice on this issue
i am due with my third baby in november
it's a girl and i have a few names
picked out that i like but there's one
name that i like more than the others
that name is fiona before we found out
my second was a boy i tossed his name
around and my husband ended up falling
in love with it i had mentioned it to
family and friends who have asked rookie
mistake and now i am having a girl i'm
bringing it back up the problem is i
think everyone hates it whenever i see
the name their face changes a little or
they actually say they don't like it
they also oh they also almost always
mention shrek
so now when everybody has a literal
queen
body positive queen
so now whenever my husband mentions it i
pretend i'm unsure about it because
everyone has made me so insecure i need
opinions and validation from girls with
taste princess fiona is a cultural icon
and the name is actu or and is the name
actually pretty or should we go with
something more common for reference my
other kids names are charlotte and
benjamin we call him benny love you
please help so i want to say that um i
have no problem with the name fiona but
it doesn't match charlotte and benjamin
okay i i like the name fiona i've never
would have thought of it but i really i
like it a lot so i think you should feel
good about that i'm sorry no i feel like
i need to be honest i really don't like
the name you don't no because of shrek
no
you don't like the
maybe it's because it reminds me of um
emmy rossum's character in
shameless who was literally the worst
character on the planet um i don't know
i just don't like the name i like it and
it's it's an interesting name so i
understand why it's you know a little
polarizing but what i'll say is that if
you love it
it literally doesn't matter if other
people like it or not because like your
act and i know this is like sounds
cliche but like you're the one who has
to live with it and if it like brings
you joy and like your baby just feels
like a fiona and like it only it
literally only matters what you think it
does not matter whatever things your
opinion is superior it's the only one
that matters but um because they're not
with you every single day and eventually
if the baby's fiona like they'll come
around to it so don't worry about that
yeah
it's completely up to you and if you're
asking me i like the name i would not do
you think it matches charlotte and
benjamin no because those are extremely
traditional and fiona's a little bit off
the beaten path but charlotte the
angelman and fiance
charlotte benny and fiona it's cute no
it's not working for me okay why don't
you offer some suggestions okay
charlotte benjamin and claudia
charlotte benjamin and theodora
charlotte benjamin and streis
that's beautiful let me see like claudia
i'm sorry not claudio charlotte like the
way they're just both written out
they're like long you know what i
actually i have the right name for you
it matches
madeline
sophia
because it's like
she likes that f oh and it matches with
charlotte it's like a royal name
i like sofia with an f i like madeline i
like madeline just seeing them written
out like they're long stately names yeah
charlotte benjamin and madeline
think about it
i like those names but i also like fiona
and it only matters what you like yeah
you know what this is like one of those
moments in your life where like it's
nice to get other people's opinions but
yours is the one that matters by the way
you liked it for your last kid and you
still like it yeah holds up that's true
it's a test of time it ages well
that's true best of luck to you
seriously it's the hardest thing in the
world they don't tell you yeah it is by
the way the hardest thing in the world
to name a human being can we talk about
how we still don't know kylie's baby's
name i have to tell you i like love this
so much from her that she's taking her
time with it i believe she does have a
name yeah i love that she's not telling
us and
normalize having a hard time
naming a human being and normalize
changing your mind yes
like literally it's such a big decision
the fact that you have to sign that
birth certificate and then bounce it
like live with that decision for the
rest of your life like normalize
changing your mind about things
totally
um so that is a special guest that is
our show that was your toasters if you
ever want to write in it's dear toasters
gmail.com hope you guys enjoyed today's
episode we're back tomorrow and friday
with two more fabulous episodes because
that's what we do uh that's what we do
thank you so much for listening to the
morning testimony morning show where we
deliver the best live stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube [ __ ] subscribe before i
ring your [ __ ] neck out nope
don't forget to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
to podcast anywhere podcast can be found
so it's spotify itunes stitcher public
radio i have radio cast box all the
places so wherever you listen to podcast
find us morning toast leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
mogul-like energy we are hope you guys
have an amazing hump day don't forget to
hump someone you love and we'll see you
tomorrow goodbye
[Music]
you